trying to get that physical play early as
Anderson getting the opportunity again on
the top line with Suzuki and Coffield no ad
doson at the line towards the net right in
front barel what a stop and a follow up as well
Z that b early he makes a sa that wasn't bad but
it was nothing compared to Mono effort doson
spots barzel it's that toe over there and then
one more time on Andre's lead coming through the
athleticism and the strength Montreal controls
Suzuki Coffield down low passes for Suzuki
Nick Suzuki Monahan Suzuki Coffield to put
it in and draw some Checkers a little higher so
when mon kicks this back out on a career high
seven game point streak Cole Coffield Suzuki
tried to round that through bounc towards at
Monahan and there's Cole Cofield fishing
no whistle yet and now they'll blow it
down Cole Coffield works the boards to Suzuki
Suzuki Coffield mat Monahan high slot the ti
right drown over Nick Suzuki first goal of 10
games Power Play marker and Montreal's got the
lead that is something to behold the key to
any successful power play get the puck in
the middle of the ice when Monahan slides out
and gets this Puck everyone drawn out towards
him again Mayfield leads the front of the net
that leaves Suzuki all alone for slapovi to
recognize there's a pass there Monahan
slowski the assists one other Montreal
here's Noah doson across Romanov loads up and
mono steers that bouncing high and picked up
by barel Matt barzel that tough game versus
Ottawa Anderson did have a little jump in
his step towards the late stages of that
game if you can dig a positive out of that
one AO lost the puck top bounce Caufield in
CFI go what a goal Co C field two nothing
Montreal [Applause] man turn over here by Ang
ball and Coffield goes to work put on your dancing
shoes oh my goodness stick handle stick handle
attack the triangle by buluk and then power to
the far side of the net he may be smaller helex
takes the opportunity off the glass down the
ice to montmo Coffield just limped off the ice
favoring his left leg hunched over on the bench
we'll keep an eye on how he's feeling mat over the
line Mike Mat cruising in pass it front score sh
ban with 1 second left of the power
play Monahan makes it three nothing
Montreal Sean Monahan continues his
fine season but what a rush by Matson
right around Romanov nobody covering
Monahan in front that is atrocious
penalty killing in comes Michael petta big
hit on pellet Pond battling in the corner
K freeze it possett right
on rebound hurard he can't
finish over a minute of five on three time
zson plays catch Nelson and doson now barzel
barzel back door feed score beautiful pass Bo
Horvat power play goal and the Islanders get
one by monum boo it's 3-1 with with a minute 44
left in Jake Evans penalty sputtering offensive
group five on three David Savar gets his stick
on this watch barzel is going to pass it through
he just heals it he just doesn't get enough to
disrupt the play Mike 20th goal of the season
for Bo Horvat team leading eighth now on the
power play and you mentioned how good he is
special teams Harvey P picks it off with Monahan
Sean mad it shoots and tied up just enough as
verlof able to keep it out get it back as the
Islanders have been bleeding chances while on
the power play Monahan jumps on this nice little
feed from Harvey penard drags it through and I
think he was looking for a call for a hook
into his hands barzel brings it in drops it
off Nelson round the net round try in front stop
Saar got across and kept it out Corvette nearly
at his second who came flying back in front
to take a sure goal away from borbat he's got
an empty net to put it into he elevates and
Saar with a kick save and a Beauty look at
this Harvard gets it to Pearson 10 seconds left
in the penalty comes all the way to Anderson
Josh Anderson for Pearson in front Gallagher
Bren Gallagher jams at it hary panar there as
well it was bouncing on Gallagher still loose
basically could have put the game away in the
last power play they get it across the net
Gallagher there right where he is trying to
goes down off Dobson off his hand off his stick
you name it har Berard steps on it by accident
kicks it across again to Tanner Pearson
it was that close to caring imp pass for
Lov and what would have been barzel to the left
side back to barzel he'll feed Dobson Dobson to
B doson at the Blue Line barzel in shoot
score Matt barzel up top power play goal
and the Islanders are within [Applause] one
power play has been running through barzel
all night he's been trying to pass it around find
someone else to shoot it finally he just takes it
himself Horvat gets SAR out now there's the draw
pvat is way out between the tops of the circle so
sard gets pulled out to into the middle of the
ice Corvette broke his stick you can attack if
you have enough energy left four on four for
a second nope not enough energy new stick and
he's back in the offensive zone and he finds
him Horvat down low Nelson the pass mat broke
it up again that drive rebound puck in front and
Mao stuck with it good pressure by the Islanders
now here's Dobson doson feeds it down low Bo
Horvat open up the scoring for the Islanders
him and barzel the goals 3-2 game pvat up top
towson's Chu stret score they come all the way
back and tied it up another Power Play goal it
is 33 the work by Paul Mary paid off and we got
a hockey game you get a five-minute power play
you make them pay by scoring a couple get back
in the game and it's Dobson's going to pick
up another point one timer is deflected wide
as work it around slowly the penalty kills have
been out for about a minute and here comes the
onetime and Paul Mary just second attempt shovel
it over top of the pad remember Islanders down
to defenseman mat watched by Nelson he'll
flip it down low strubel tried to get it in
deep Coffield good steal Coffield cross ice
Anderson in across score M hand [Applause]
second brutal giveaway by P angal what is he
doing deep into a shift he turns it over no
structure behind him and it goes side to side
teeing up for Shawn Monahan 30 seconds left to
the period Horvat tries to Center and he will
Nelson for doson Dobson across to barzel that
barzel in front p weak shot Puck loose side of
that big block kevich out's control head shot
left P save Again by Mono Drive in front again
for mono he stops that across Horvat on the p b
Horvat hit the iron that drive side of the net
8 seconds left Montreal trying to hang on Lee
side of the net bounce to the four corner and the
Montreal Canadians hang on and take it 4- three